[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the murders of reggie and carol sumner
frida guinea did not create a monster he
chose to be one there's nothing that can
happen in this courtroom
that can undo what happened 17 years ago
will convicted killer alan wade be
sentenced to death and the candy the dog
civil trial at this point i was
screaming rod get your dog rod get your
dog rod get your dog i was i mean i
yield myself horse hear testimony from
the man responsible for candy's death
plus kevin spacey faces multiple counts
of sexual assault in the united kingdom
court but first accused husband killer
danielle redlich stands trial you see
over and over and over again the lengths
that this defendant will go to to avoid
having to answer for what she did not
guilty
[Music]
she did what she had to do
to escape the situation here closing
arguments from both sides before a
verdict is reached law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
your host brian buckman after just hours
of deliberation a verdict is reached in
the trial of a florida of florida versus
danielle redlich the woman accused of
murdering her stepfather turned husband
redling is charged with second-degree
murder and evidence tampering for the
murder of her husband michael redlich
redlich claims she killed him in
self-defense when she stabbed him in
2019. the two had been married for
nearly 20 years and had two children
together defense attorneys say the
couple's relationship had a history of
abuse and cheating the couple had also
reportedly filed for divorce by the time
of michael's death 9-1-1 calls reveal
redlich initially told dispatchers that
michael stabbed himself and had a heart
attack investigators say she waited
several hours before calling for help
the night of his death before a verdict
was reached jurors heard closing
arguments from both sides in his closing
argument prosecutors said redlich's
testimony was not believable
at the end of the day this case is
in some large measure about her
credibility and what you heard
is that every single statement that came
out of her mouth
until she sat in that chair until she
had to look you folks in the eye
was a denial of responsibility
the state of florida submits to you that
her testimony before you over the course
of a day and a half was just one more
attempt to avoid responsibility
for her actions
to avoid not being held responsible for
the murder she knew she
she committed as she stood over michael
with the power to call 9-1-1
in the decision not to
in its closing argument defense
attorneys argued redlich stabbed her
husband only once in self-defense
that man
stopping her from breathing
pressing her up against the island
has his hands on her face
she pulls out the knife she grabs the
knife and he reengages
grabs his hand
back goes her face
now comes the knife
she doesn't have to get away there
only way that she's able to escape
is by doing what she did
and we know
that her goal was to escape
because she stabbed him one time if
she's stabbing him out of hatred
it will spite
probably seeing more than one stab wound
there
probably not to the shoulder
after only several hours of
deliberations the jurors reached a
verdict as to both charges
state of florida versus danielle justine
redlin
verdict has to count one we the jury
find the defendant not guilty so say we
all signed juror badge number 283 for
person
special findings this page was left play
verdict as to count two we the jury find
the defendant guilty of tampering with
physical evidence as charged in the
information so say we all signed german
number 283 for person
dated at orlando orange county florida
on the 17th day of june 2022
relic is set to be sentenced on august
5th for the tampering with evidence
conviction the judge denied the
defense's motion to release redlich
following the verdict but she could be
released on 15 thousand dollar bond
pending sentence joining us today is
forensic death investigator joseph scott
morgan and co-host terry austin joseph
i've been waiting to have you on to ask
you this i think a lot of people are
curious about it what exactly did
danielle redlick hit when she stabbed
her husband in order to cause him to die
within six minutes
yeah that's a great question brian good
to be with you guys if you begin to
think about your clavicle in this
particular area there's a whole complex
of blood vessels that run through there
both arteries and veins
miss redlich actually clipped one of
those veins which is of course a return
vessel that supplies the arm
and he began to bleed out into what's
called the interstitial tissue remember
the pathologist said they couldn't
measure that blood but what's key here
is that she penetrated the chest wall
and went into the upper lobe of the left
lung the left lung only has two lobes
and he began to bleed out into that
pleural space and it prevented him from
breathing he lost about a liter of blood
brian we only have about five in our
body yeah all right interesting so
somewhere around here i guess that makes
sense now terry
not guilty of the two top counts the
defense made an argument for release but
the judge denied it can you explain the
back and forth and was the judge right
in your opinion
i think the judge was wrong and she
should not have to go back to jail you
know in florida tampering with evidence
is five years she's already served three
and a quarter the judge should have let
her out on her own recognizance and the
defense counsel was trying to argue that
saying that if you apply the sentencing
guidelines she has no prior record she's
going to come back with years less than
the maximum sentence and so she should
be let out and furthermore she's not a
danger to society so wrong decision but
hopefully she'll get out on the bond as
you mentioned yeah i would expect the
defense to file what's called a writ of
habeas corpus to go to a higher court
law and crime will be there if that
happens next week to see whether or not
she gets out pending a sentence
an update now on a story we first
brought you here on law and crime daily
as new hampshire investigators zero in
on the apartment of harmony montgomery's
father the missing girl has not been
seen for three years this week officials
took a closer look at the apartment
where harmony's father adam montgomery
and stepmother caleb montgomery lived
during the investigation a refrigerator
and other items were removed from the
apartment and a camera dropped down a
nearby sewer pipe adam montgomery is
being held in jail on charges of abusing
harmony before she went missing so far
he has not been charged in connection to
her disappearance caleb montgomery has
been charged with fraud for collecting
food stamps in harmony's name after the
girl went missing harmony was last seen
in 2019 when living with her father and
stepmother in manchester new hampshire a
reward for more information about her
whereabouts is set for 150 thousand
dollars
still ahead on law and crime daily the
man who shot and killed candy the dog
testifies in the civil trial but first
kevin spacey appears in a united kingdom
court on sexual assault charges
[Music]
welcome back academy award winner kevin
spacey is granted bail as he faces four
charges of sexual assault in the united
kingdom spacey who appeared in court
overseas on thursday was granted
unconditional bail meaning he can head
back to the united states before his
next court date the actor faces charges
of sexual assault dating back to 2005
2008 and 2013 and three different male
accusers this isn't the actor's first
run-in with claims against him he's
faced more than a dozen sexual
misconduct allegations since 2017.
spacey's acting career came into an
abrupt halt when actor anthony rapp
accused him of sexually assaulting him
at a party when rap was just a teenager
spacey is due back in the english court
on july 14 for his next hearing
tier what does it mean to be granted
bail in this kind in this context and
what's life for spacey going to be like
until a plea or trial
well you know he's very lucky that he
got that unconditional bail it was his
first appearance in the uk court and he
came voluntarily which is probably part
of the reason that the court gave him
this unconditional bill and what it
means brian is he is supposed to remain
outside of prison while he's awaiting
that trial he has no further
restrictions and he could have gotten
restrictions like having to wear an
ankle bracelet or not being able to
travel so fortunately he can travel his
next appearance as you mentioned is july
14th and they've already said that he's
coming back to the united states to be
with his family and perhaps to work so
he'll be able to do all the things that
he's you know been trying to do all
along absolutely joseph i know there's
no death investigation here but i want
to ask you about some of the evidence
space he's facing charges from between
2005 to 2013 what kind of evidence do
you think we can expect in a case this
old and spans this long
it's going to be very very difficult
brian and remember one of these charges
is actually
and i'm paraphrasing it's like a
non-consensual penetrative sex or forced
sex charge and generally in in sexual
cases like this from a forensic
standpoint what we generally do is look
for trauma that occurs within those
moments and you have to have it examined
because healing takes place and then we
do sample of course we've all heard
about rape kits well this applies across
the board whether it's male or female
this has not been done to the best of my
knowledge so they're going to really be
lacking on physical evidence a lot of
the stuff is going to be circumstantial
brian yeah it's going to be he says he
says he says he says of a case i guess
without much science to back it up and
we'll of course keep eyes on this case
as it continues across the pond
coming up on law and crime daily will
convicted killer alan wade be sentenced
to death in florida plus the candy the
dog civil trough we head to florida as
the man who shot and killed candy takes
the stand
[Music]
welcome back to plaintiff rest and the
defendant takes to stand as the
defense's first witness in the candy the
dog civil trial as a florida dog owner
works to bring justice for the 2016
death of his beloved companion rodney
jacobson filed the civil suit against
zachary deterly saying dieterly wrongly
shot his dog candy it happened six years
ago on dieterley's father's property
where jacobson stored his boat candy was
off leash when she approached dieterly
he claims the dog was in an attack
stance that's when deedley shot the dog
twice with a revolver the sarasota
county sheriff's office says didily was
not charged because he had a permit to
carry the weapon and that he was within
his rights to use deadly force because
he feared for his life jacobson says
candy had no history of aggression he
says the ultimate goal of the trial is
for the sarasota sheriff's office to
determine the shooting was not justified
and to file criminal charges against
deterly dietally testified friday that
on the day of the shooting he saw a
large pit bull as he approached jacobson
to say hello he described what he says
happened leading up to the shooting
did the dog coming out unexpectedly
scare you
yes i
was certainly not expecting that walking
around the property and what did you do
in response to the dog snarling and
running at you i immediately turned to
face it i didn't want to turn my back on
what i was starting to perceive as a
threat
and sort of yelled at it sort of hey dog
hey dog
did the dog come back at you after i
made the first loop yeah went back and
came back
in at me at this point i was screaming
rod get your dog rod get your dog rod
get your dog i was i mean i yield myself
horse i couldn't i could hardly talk the
next day this is the only time i had
ever had an animal react to me that way
when you have 24 years old at the time
and grew up around dogs it was strange
it was totally alien
terry based on deterly and jacobs in
testimony do you think officers were
right not to charge dealy with killing
candy
i do i don't think the sheriff had
enough information to charge any
criminal case here based on what we've
heard from dieterle he was afraid for
his life and he did not shoot the dog
and he wasn't trying to be cruel in any
way shape or form in florida you'd have
to show
animal cruelty for a criminal charge and
he could have gotten jail time for that
but i think the sheriff was right
because there was no torture here there
was no mutilation here obviously he
didn't fail to feed the dog those are
the types of
claims you'd have to show for a criminal
case frankly i'm not even sure they're
going to be able to prove a civil case
here because i do think that doodly made
a good witness on the stand he was a
little bit arrogant but he did make the
jury feel as though he was afraid for
his life you know joseph i know that you
are a father of three rescues and i'm
adobe dad myself so the question is who
do you believe will win in this civil
case based on what you've seen so far
i think it's going to be a very uh
very high hill to climb uh for for this
uh for for for the plaintiffs in this
particular case uh because you know the
guy he's stating that he did fear for
his life i think it's a tragic outcome
but the expect i don't know that it's
going to necessarily meet the standard
of preponderance of evidence here to tip
the tip the scales in his way
uh because the guy plainly you know
stated that he feared for his life even
said that candy went into an attack
stance i don't necessarily know what
that means but
for his perception it was that the dog
was about to uh essentially jump on him
i guess that's what he was thinking and
he drew the weapon and ended candy's
alive
yeah the unfortunate reality is i always
tell people when you have certain dogs
they've got to be trained to an extent
that other people are not fearful of
them when i say i'm adobe dad i have a
doberman pinscher which i think most
people know are someone intimidating
dogs and if you keep them off leash like
the boxers or or the pipples they're
loving and adoring dogs but many people
are fearful of them so i i don't see
this going for
for the plaintiff in a very strong way
but we'll continue to see it until the
verdict comes out when we come back a
defendant is resentenced for a murder
more than a decade ago after closing
statements are presented what did a jury
decide for the fate of alan wayne
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily a man
convicted of murder more than a decade
ago will spend the rest of his life in
prison instead of being put to death as
alan wade is re-sentenced in a florida
courtroom
wade along with three others michael
james jackson tiffany cole and bruce
nixon were convicted in 2008 for their
involvement in the 2005 murder of reggie
and carol sumner a jury found the four
guilty of killing the couple they
kidnapped the summoners stole from the
couple's home then forced them into the
trunk of their own car before burying
them alive three of the four were given
the death penalty wade and jackson are
being re-sentenced separately after a
change in florida law which requires a
unanimous vote for the death penalty
after the jury's verdict was read the
judge brought wade up to the bench to
issue his new sentence
mr wade you have previously been found
guilty by a jury of your peers of the
homicides of carol and reggie sumner
another jury of your peers having
found that you should be
the senate should be imposed against you
should be life imprisonment might but
not death
uh i hereby impose that sentence i will
imagine the cuts to the department of
corrections of the state of florida to
remain in custody for the remainder of
your natural life
before the verdict was read and the
judge re-sentenced wade both sides
presented their closing arguments
prosecutors asked jurors to keep his
previous sentence the death penalty
carol and reggie sumner after years of
loneliness found each other and swore to
each other
that they would be together until death
never could they have imagined how
heinous atrocious and cruel
those deaths would be
the terrifying ordeal at the hands of
this defendant
each and every one of you took an oath
and you swore
asking god for help the in the right
case
that you would be able to individually
check the box that says death
time in no way shape or form has dulled
these evil acts
your verdict
will penetrate through time
to forever defy
the punishment that is just
for what he did
way's defense attorney argued whenever
the jury decided that wade will die in
prison and that nothing can change the
past
no matter what you decide
you will spend the rest of his days
in the concrete box of prison
until he dies under either scenario the
punishment he receives is a harsh one if
putting alan wade to death would bring
back the sumners
i may do it myself
but unfortunately
that is not the way
life works there's nothing that can
happen in this courtroom
that can undo what happened 17 years ago
joseph do you think wade's plead to the
jury in the end was what saved him
yeah i suppose that it did
he got before that jury and he he made
his case
as to why he should be allowed to live
and you know at the end of the day
that's what it comes down to but i take
exception what council said right there
at the end
nothing you can do can change this and
back 15 or 17 years ago well the fact is
it did happen and out of all the cases
i've ever covered this is one of the
most horrific
speaking of cases that you've covered
joseph scott morgan's podcast body bags
on this very case examining the
forensics in each and every detail comes
out june 21st make sure to check it out
and all of his phenomenal stories many
of which we cover here at the law and
crime daily terry can you break down the
verdict for us the fact that there's no
death penalty does that mean everyone
said no death penalty or was it kind of
a mixed bag on the voting
well you know unless we talk to the
jurors we really aren't going to know
that what we do know brian is that in
order to impose the death penalty in
florida you have to have a unanimous
verdict of 12. clearly they did not have
that so it could have been one person
only or it could have been several of
the jurors who said no i cannot impose
the death penalty and i agree
wholeheartedly i do think that um you
know
this was heinous the jury found that you
know it wasn't heinous i i agree with um
you know joseph this was a heinous crime
i don't know why the jury couldn't come
back with that i think it is hard for
jurors to impose the death penalty they
said it was cold and calculated they
didn't think it was heinous it was
heinous and look it only took them three
and a half hours so clearly some of
those jurors already made up their mind
even before they went back in that room
and it's hard to convince a jury to go
another way on the death sentence yeah
it's hard to get that death penalty
sentence on many of these cases i think
the defense pushed it pretty well to win
for their kind thank you both for always
coming and thank you for joining us here
at long crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you